une graine au tec un bar à bonbons ou
encore des aliments exotiques
voilà de quoi ravir les papilles des
petits et grands gourmands présent
aujourd'hui nous sommes au démarrage de
la semaine du goût donc ne rendrai cet
événement et si à lille de loisirs pour
sensibiliser les gens alors vers il ya
différentes
ces activités dont une qui est une
graine au tec qui nous permet de
de faire retrouver aux gens eux
de retrouver les et des aliments qui ne
connaissent pas forcément ou qu'ils ont
oublié à l'initiative l'association je
respecte ma ville née d'une volonté de
sauvegarder la propreté des espaces de
vie est de sensibiliser au tri des
déchets l'association lance
régulièrement des actions comme ici sur
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines je respecterai ville et un
associant éco citoyenne qui a pour but
de sensibiliser les gens plus ou moins
jeunes les au respect du cadre de vie
sur place se trouve uniquement des
artisans locaux et des produits
provenant du commerce équitable une
journée qui sensibilise le plus grand
nombre au bien manger et au patrimoine
culinaire